so recently we had big maths news think
we had that new prime number that was
found and it was the biggest prime
number ever found and it was big news
and we were all quite excited about it
it was lots of fun but it got me
thinking about one of the classic proofs
in mathematics and that is the proof
that there are infinitely many primes so
even though we found this huge 17
million digit prime number it is still
not the biggest prime number of all
because there's infinitely many of them
so shall we do this classic proof
so I'll say before I start that many of
you may have seen this proof before it
goes way back but for those who haven't
seen it before this is what
mathematicians consider an elegant and a
beautiful proof so we're going to prove
infinitely many primes to do that first
of all we're going to assume the
opposite so I'm going to say there are
finitely many Prime's so if there's
finitely many of them we can write a
list and let's do that I'm going to call
them Prime one don't know what it is it
particularly but let's call it prime 1
prime 2 prime 3 and I just go on until I
get to the last one which I'll call
prime n the point I want to make though
is that this is a complete list so
that's important ok the next thing I'm
going to do I'm going to make a new
number it's a whole number I'm going to
call it Q so let's call it Q and to make
this number I'm going to multiply all
these together prime 1 times Prime 2 x
prime 3 all the way up to the last one
there prime n so there will be only one
way to write Q as a product of primes
it's a unique expression so there's only
one way you can write Q and then I'm
going to add one Q is either prime or
it's not that's the only options it has
if Q is prime then it's a new prime
that's not on this list that's bad so
hopefully it's not a prime if it's not a
prime then it is made up from primes
by multiplying Prime's together now
those prime factors of Q will divide Q
exactly and here's the problem none of
these Prime's on my list divide Q
exactly they'll divide this number
perfectly but not this plus one number
you'll always have one left over so the
prime factors are not on this list so
this list is not complete I said if
there's finitely many of them I can have
a complete list you cannot and that's
the proof that our infinitely many
so the definition of a prime is that
it's the building blocks of other
numbers so all other whole numbers are
made by multiplying Prime's together so
Q is a whole number and it is made by
multiplying primes together and in this
case the problem is none of the Prime's
on my list do that trick
they don't divide the number exactly so
there's Prime's missing what I've got
here is a copy of a book called Euclid's
elements and this is a textbook written
by a Greek mathematician called Euclid
now you could live in 300 BC so this
textbook is 2,300 years old it's never
been out of print and it's you know
second only to the Bible in that respect
it's one of the most important books in
mathematics is one of the most important
books in human history and the proof
that there are infinitely many Prime's
is in here and I checked it out earlier
it was on to page 2 to 7 which is book 9
proposition 20 and it is right there
the proof that there are infinitely many
Prime's there's a couple of differences
from this proof to what I did one
difference is my proof there was
something called a proof by
contradiction it's something that
mathematicians do a lot it's really
useful
what Euclid did was slightly different
he assumed that there was a list of
primes and he said but you can keep
adding to it so you can never complete
the list which is the same sort of idea
the other difference is that this book
was written in the days before algebra
so he didn't have algebra to use like I
did so all his proofs are using straight
lines and circles so it looks quite
different but it's actually quite easy
to translate into modern terms you see
mathematics is the search for truth and
this book is as true today as it was
2,300 years ago we know a prime number
can only be divided by 1 and itself by
no other factors so how did you could
define it it's actually in here I was
quite excited when I found this so let's
have a look in definitions look here at
the beginning of book seven he defines
terms look at that a prime number it's
that which is measured by a unit alone
so only units fit into the prime number
it was all measured with lines so the
length of a line with length a prime can
only fit units into it you can't fit
twos and threes and other lengths into
it
so if we had something that was prime
length let's make it or a seven there we
go
then you can fit ones into it two three
four five six seven but you wouldn't be
able to fit twos into it so here's a two
and that would not fit into my length
seven or if I tried you know fours or
threes it wouldn't fit into my length
seven so a prime length would only fit
units into it and itself and that's the
definition of primes we have today so
what does that mean for that that that
new prime number that was found
it's just eat study that new prime
number seventeen million digits long
tiny nothing insignificant to the whole
infinity of prime numbers it is small
Phi my understandings that program has
become less frequent the higher you go
their density becomes lower does that
mean the next prime number is likely to
be a long way away from those seventeen
million digits they become more spaced
out you are right about that and there's
a we book getting into other things here
but there are some fantastic theories or
theorems about how the prime numbers are
spaced out the density of prime numbers
but we are sipping into other realms
there sounds like another video it does
sound like another video it'll be a good
one as well